tasci als stellvertretender
bundesvorsitzender der partei müssen sie
natürlich jetzt das wahlergebnis lob und
die afg hat ja in der tat in beiden
bundesländern gewaltig zugelegt aber von
parlamentarische verantwortung sind sie
ja trotzdem meilenweit entfernt das sehe
ich nicht so sondern auch eine
opposition kann ja gute arbeit machen
auf der anderen seite müssen sich
natürlich die anderen parteien fragen
wie sie mit der hälfte in zukunft
umgehen denn der wählerwille sagt ja
ganz eindeutig die afg soll
offensichtlich in
regierungsverantwortung und wenn sie
auch die wähler der fdp sehen genau die
wähler sagen ja wir möchten die fdp in
regierungsverantwortung sehen also wenn
die fdp diesmal nicht drankommt bin ich
sicher dass sie ergebnisse beim nächsten
mal noch besser werden fragen sie die
wähler erwarten dass sie in
regierungsverantwortung kommen denken
sie dass es noch schaffen einen keil in
die sächsische cdu zu treiben dass die
partei die cdu sich vielleicht noch mal
überlegt ob sie eine kenia koalition
macht oder ein bündnis mit ihnen also
ich könnte mir zumindest vorstellen dass
man darüber nachdenken muss
die andere geschichte ist ja auch man
muss man überlegen ob man auch eine
minderheitenregierung nicht tolerieren
kann denn herr kretschmann hat ganz
eindeutig gesagt vor den wahlen dass er
mit den grünen nicht zusammen gehen
möchte wenn er jetzt dieses versprechen
bricht dann bricht er ja auch gegenüber
seinen wählern das versprechen also er
muss klug handeln und er muss vor allen
dingen auch die richtige entscheidung
treffen und den wählerwillen davon nicht
ignorieren aber seinen wäldern hat er
vor allen dingen versprochen in keinem
fall mit ihnen zu koalieren oder auch
nur ein bündnis zu akzeptieren ja wissen
sie ich weiß nicht wie lange dieser
schuhe halten wird es ist auf jeden fall
so man wird auf dauer die afg nicht
ausgrenzen können 25 27.5
der wähler kann man nicht ausgrenzen
also jeder vierte wähler hat afg gewählt
und das zeigt eigentlich ganz ganz
deutlich was der wähler in sachsen
möchte und was der wähler auch in
brandenburg möchte die anderen parteien
grenzen sich von der afg ab aber auch
viele politiker ihrer partei grenzen
sich von anderen parteien ab muss wenn
ich die afg auch noch etwas ändern
nein denke ich nicht ich glaube wir
haben hier im moment haben wir ja alle
parteien gegen die afd
das halte ich für einen fehler weil
letzten endes muss unsere demokratie ja
funktionieren
unsere demokratie funktioniert nur wenn
man auch den wählerwillen akzeptierten
der wählerwille sagt ganz eindeutig
halte es mit der afg versuche es mit der
afg und ich bin auch sicher dass das
mittelfristig auch der fall sein wird es
wird genauso kommen wie bei den grünen
dass die afg genauso koalitionsfähig für
andere parteien werden wird und dann
werden wir die politik mitgestalten das
ist möglicherweise der herbst der
rechten flügel männer in der afd
kalbitz und urban jetzt in brandenburg
und sachsen gewonnen hätte
möglicherweise mit einem guten ergebnis
in thüringen ende oktober könnte es für
einen moderaten wie für sie in der
partei der nicht zum flügel gehört auf
dem bundesparteitag in braunschweig
anfang dezember eng werden wenn die
parteispitze neu gewählt wird
das sehe ich nicht so denn gerade bei
der wahl der parteispitze kommt ja
darauf an wer kann das wer ist bereit
sich einzubringen wer hat die kompetenz
und wir sind eine partei das heißt auch
die personen in der partei werden
natürlich ihre wahl danach ausrichten
dass sie sagen was ist für die partei am
besten und da bin ich doch sehr
hoffnungsvoll dass wir den richtigen
pohl und bundesvorstand kriegen werden
die auch die parteien die richtige
richtung führt